hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
clever wo ich habe so viele kommentare
gesehen dass ich leute wieder clever bot
gewünscht haben und die letzte folge ist
natürlich jetzt auch irgendwie circa
vier jahre her deswegen befinden uns
wieder hier beim clever bot und werden
ich weiß über was sollen wir mit dem
reden habe jetzt gar keine gedanken
tatsächlich voll gemacht da wir so lange
nicht mehr mit ihm geredet haben stelle
ich einfach mal als erste frage kennst
du mich ich kenne stege nein ich meine
milch alles klar und dann ist ja wir
hatten es doch vorher den anderen folgen
immer so zu beginnen wir hatten da immer
so gefragt ob der weiß was ich anhabe um
zu schauen ob er klug ist ja welche
farbe hat mein t shirt und er antwortet
dein t-shirt hat die farbe blättert ist
das ist mein vater ein t shirt die farbe
luca shop als nächstes frage ich ihn
einfach mal welche farbe hat meine
boxershorts da antwortet er was für eine
farbe haben meine haare lauda so lau
fragezeichen deine hose hat die farbe
blau wie sie braucht er jetzt nur blau
gesagt wenn ich gesagt habe dass seine
haare bzw
sein gehirn da oben blau sind ich bin
blaum sowas anvisiert schreibt der
körper wort nämlich auf die antwort dass
ich betrunken und glauben welche
verharrten
vorhin fragte mich was für eine farbe
haben meine haare und jetzt welche
haarfarbe habe ich willst du mich
verarschen blau fragezeichen und blaue
das ist keine haarfarbe höchstens eine
färbung dass er richtig klug geworden
als maul halten
ach ich liebe unser verhältnis clever
wollen nachdem er den jetzt ein bisschen
was gefragt haben über mich frage ich
jetzt einfach mal über die hier hinten
faktisch ist ja fucking herr kollege
jetzt der ace kennst du noch cool wie
fragezeichen und er schreibt kevin und
stewart ukulele bist du eine frau ist
ukulele noch mal eine frau oder ein mann
ich glaube werden mal gesagt dass
ökologie eine frau ist weil der ball und
vitale schon männlich ist was für eine
begründung alter ok egal kennst du
wenigstens balu fragezeichen und der
antwortet nur den von kika live den vom
titel life remseck in slate wenn ich
titel life ball umg bekommen solche
ganzen sachen und ich war wieso ist er
verfügt nochmal babys beauty palace man
ich werde nicht mehr da geht schon hier
sind sogar er nie und werde noch mal
hier
wir haben noch dann haben wir hier noch
wir haben hunde tatsächlich sehr sehr
viele wir haben den verpackten baby
twitter im auge
mit diesen fakten ansatz da oben ich
schreibe jetzt mal einfach vitello ist
hier kennst du mich fragezeichen und der
kleine ort antwort darauf ganz gediegen
mit der tolle nachricht dass der clever
bot irgendwie gerade gar nicht antwortet
halt deine schnauze
ja ich meine warum auch nicht alle
fragen gingen bisher nur darum dass ich
den klub ort gefragt habe etwas
was hat dein deutsch ich frage jetzt
einfach mal wer bist du eigentlich lieb
ich sage meinen namen nicht anzeichen
sagt mir den ersten buchstaben kommen
sagt du mir deinen namen okay wie heißt
du noch mal keinen sinn ich hab sie ja
gerade beantwortet luca rio punkt so
hajduk warum luca oder es lieber ist das
dein name ja das ist mein name clever
bond ich heiße luca ohne es dann bist du
ein mann richtig liebe aber das ist
richtig dass also super erkannt und
jetzt kommt die nächste antwort von ihm
wahrscheinlich wieder so etwas in die
richtung wie ich soll meine fresse
halten
welche farbe hat mein shirt keine ahnung
man sagt mir deinen namen ich will
einfach wissen wie der kletterwald heiß
alter das kann nicht sein wer werden wer
steckt denn dahinter ich glaube
javascript oder wir kommen ganz schön
bisschen er wer steckt hinter dir keine
ahnung wüsste ich auch gerne
wir kriegen das noch raus mit dem
schreibe ich hier mit mir gehts erreicht
wenn wir nicht italie testet es weil du
vielleicht ein maß mensch bist 8,3 fh
dfb
wie soll man so etwas richtig
kommentieren es geht einfach nicht wer
bist du ich bin ich und wer bist du ich
bin ich und wer bist du ich bin auch ich
kann mir das niemals einlassen ich bin
ebenfalls ich und wer bist denn du seit
wann bist du denn mit klima unter luka
ich kann nicht das ist ich bin ich nicht
mit ihm aus die backe ich bin ich bin
ich bin jetzt ich bin hier wie viel geld
zu geben damit er ruhig bist verrate ich
nicht sag doch bitte man lieber gegen
nein sagst du
doch auch nicht doch 2010 sind sie
milliarden euro soll lieber clever wurde
jetzt ich bin keine frau denn woher
willst du es auch wissen ich habe den
clever bot jetzt einfach mal gefragt
clever bot ich weiß nicht wer du bist
oder wo du herkommst oder was du willst
oder ob die pizza marx oder sonst was
aber ich will gern blitzen mit dem ich
es hier zu tun habe verstehst du
ich will es doch einfach nur wissen wo
gerade seine antwort reingekommen und
seine antwort ist kennst du meine
haarfarbe fragezeichen ist blau deine
lieblingsfarbe
ich kann mir das nicht mehr geben ich
werde in diesen clever bordvideos mit
kompletter dummheit zugeballert wie
mitkommen in meinem gesicht rein und ich
denke mir neue war wie warum ich bin ich
mein mann iq sinkt nach clever
bordvideos immer um 20 punkte
ich beende an dieser stelle das video
wenn es euch gefallen natürlich nicht um
eine bewertung freuen wollt ihr wieder
mehr clever bot dann schreib mir mal
themen die kommentare mehr sehen nicht
mit dem clever bottrop diskutiert oder
reden
ciao